these ethical concerns don't come about
because of simple binary choices between
being good or evil they come about
largely because of lack of awareness
today on chalk radio we're talking about
how the ethical decisions of engineers
shape the software we use every day
ultimately through going through this
like concrete process the goal is to get
you to identify what we call value-laden
decision points in your engineering work
and to choose better
just through being more informed and
deliberate
i'm your host sarah hansen
this week we're in conversation with two
mit scientists who are thinking deeply
about how software design impacts our
experiences in the world
they're also encouraging students to
examine the fault lines between humans
and technology
and helping students to consider the
social and ethical responsibilities of
computing
my guests are daniel jackson and serena
booth i'm a professor of computer
science and i'm
also an associate director of csail the
computer science and ai lab at mit
i'm entering my fourth year as a phd
student here at mit
before collaborating in the classroom
daniel and serena were both conducting
research at the intersection of complex
technology and everyday human
experiences
the focus of my work in the last few
years
has been to try and understand
design of software
not from the point of view of its
internal structure
which by the way is what people actually
mean when they talk about designing
software they mean how do you write the
code how do you organize the code how do
you fit things together and so on
but rather design in the sense that
anyone out there in the world
would use the term namely design at the
interface between machine and human
being and i've become very interested in
the question of essentially whether we
can come up with a kind of grand theory
of design that can explain
how to design software so that it's more
usable more secure more safe and more
pleasant
i really want to create like useful
general purpose robots which collaborate
with people so it's important to me that
robots don't replace people they
accentuate the things that we like in
our lives and take away some of the
chores and the boring things i think we
often forget about the need for the
person to work and collaborate with that
robot that's where i'm really interested
right trying to get humans to understand
how robots work to be able to predict
what they'll do next so that you can
make this collaboration safe and useful
to both human and robot
as they've pursued their own research
they've both witnessed how different
kinds of seemingly simple design
decisions have serious social and
ethical implications
i would say you know i can i can put
them very crudely into three different
categories
the first is that it's
very easy
to design and build a device or a system
or an application that simply doesn't
fulfill its intended purpose
well a really compelling example of this
for me is the panoply of medical devices
often designed by companies that have
great technology but don't have
sufficient expertise in software and
human computer interaction design to
think about questions related to what
kinds of mistakes the users can make so
there are many horrendous stories of
infusion pumps for example in which
nurses
enter incorrect dosage rates and people
are
killed or severely injured because for
example a chemotherapy drug is delivered
at much too high concentration or much
too higher volume but medical devices
just one category of systems that are
often poorly implemented in a way that
essentially doesn't appreciate how
important it is to accommodate the kinds
of errors that the users make and i
should say there's also a a well-known
and very unfortunate tendency in society
to blame users for the errors they make
as just one example a horrendous
accident series of accidents due to a
radiotherapy machine in panama led to
all the nurses involved in it being
prosecuted and i think some of them
going to jail despite the fact that it
was clearly a system design flaw so
that's the first category things not
meeting their purposes the second
category is that they are designed to
meet certain purposes but those purposes
are insidious ones
i'll give you an example of one which is
insidious only in a mild way and that is
that a lot of applications provide some
kind of notification feature and you
might imagine that's to serve
what the words suggest and notify the
users so facebook tells you for example
when there might be posts of interest to
you
but if you dig a little deeper and you
look into the question of how easily you
can actually configure those settings
and decide what you want to be notified
about you'll discover that in fact you
have very little control and what that
reveals is that the real purpose
of this notification
concept is in fact to encourage
engagement in the site and to draw
people to visit it more frequently than
is actually good for them that's the
second category the third category
are basically the respects in which
designs
can contribute
to a computational environment that has
subtly pernicious effects and those
effects include for example
marginalizing certain groups of people
advantaging some users over others
encouraging anti-social or undemocratic
behaviors
creating damage to community or even
just personally reducing quality of life
by making us less reflective or creative
or independent by enslaving us to our
devices by sapping our attention and all
these things that you know we've all
become very concerned with with the
devices we use but which are not
necessarily inherent in those devices
but exacerbated by the design decisions
we make
i can give you an anecdote from my days
at google so i just graduated from
college i was like 22 years old i'd been
at google for a few weeks and i was
working on search and my team came to me
and we were having this this crisis we
were redesigning the the dinosaurs
search page and everyone wasn't sure
we'd gotten a lot of bugs from parents
complaining about our dinosaur search
page because uh pterodactyl didn't
appear there and their children wanted
it there and so we had this little
crisis as a team we were like should we
put pterodactyl on there it's not really
a dinosaur it's technically a pterosaur
so we would be lying to the children and
because i was a product manager they
were like okay serena you decide and so
i just made a decision and then we moved
on
and you know this is like totally
unimportant right it doesn't really
matter if the kids think pterodactyl is
a dinosaur but it just opens the door
like the floodgates to thinking about
how much control we have over how people
understand the world and so yeah those
sorts of decisions are things i think
about a lot
[Music]
serena and daniel noticed a gap between
the questions they were asking
themselves as researchers and what
students were being asked inside the
classroom
i'd always been troubled by the way in
which
we'd perhaps not only allowed but even
encouraged our students
to marginalize ethical concerns and
sometimes think of them in rather trite
terms one thing that always comes to
mind to me is that you know when google
was founded there was this slogan you
know do no evil
and there was this sense i think amongst
our students and amongst a lot of young
technologists that we're good people and
so it's understandable that we thought
we didn't want to do evil but the truth
is
most people don't want to do evil you
know the people
in charge of the companies that do some
of the most terrible things onto the
planet are really not evil people most
of them are people who you know love
their families and friends who want to
do good in the world and these ethical
concerns don't come about because the
simple binary choices between being good
or evil they come about largely because
of lack of awareness and as we've seen
with google for example money corrupts
everything and once you start to be
hugely financially successful unless you
have a very strong ethical lens
it's very hard to resist the temptations
of money and i thought it was very
important for us to be able to inoculate
our students
against some of those temptations and
for them to develop the kind of
sophistication
in their social and ethical
understanding of the world that they
have in their technological
understanding i will say also there was
a very simple pragmatic reason that i
wanted to be involved with circ which
was that i didn't know how to do this
myself
you may remember the acronym cirque from
our previous episode with catherine
ignacio jacob andreas and harini suresh
it stands for social and ethical
responsibilities of computing
so recently mit announced its launch of
the college of computing which is a new
endeavor to try to bring
cross-disciplinary computing all
together it's going to like really
change mit as we know it but as part of
that also they've launched circ the goal
is to bring all of the different
perspectives on social and ethical
responsibilities together so
philosophers social scientists cognitive
scientists computer scientists many more
and get that coalition of people to help
embed ethics education into mit's
curriculum very broadly
in collaboration with cerc serena joined
daniel as a graduate teaching assistant
for the course
6.170 software studio one of their
primary goals was to bring social and
ethical considerations into the
engineering classroom
that's when they turned to a powerful
tool called the ethics protocol the
ethics protocol was developed here at
mit it was developed by milo phillips
brown who's now an assistant professor
at oxford university and abby jakes they
are both philosophers by training and as
they matured in their careers they
started to get more involved in
designing ethics related materials for
computing specifically
so the ethics protocol is a tool which
tries to assist in their mission which
is to teach ethics as a skill
ultimately through going through this
like concrete process the goal is to get
you to identify what we call value-laden
decision points in your engineering work
and to choose better just through being
more informed and deliberate
daniel and serena noted that it's not
possible or ethical to simply give
students a singular ethical principle to
guide their decision making
instead students are introduced to a set
of three lenses that they can apply when
assessing a project or idea
the three lenses of the ethics protocol
are outcomes structure and process
the outcomes lens asks you to analyze
the consequences of a decision or
intervention and that's a very intuitive
one to use the process lens asks you to
consider the treatment of your
stakeholders so you should think about
things like your stakeholders autonomy
their consent their participation and
then that last lens the structure lens
asks you to analyze how outcomes and
process is distributed among the
stakeholders another
good and perhaps more descriptive name
for this lens would be a justice lens
so in software design we typically have
one definition for stakeholders somebody
who's involved in making using or would
be likely to use your software you're
building for a relatively small set of
people and you're trying to be very
mindful of their needs as you build
but when you think instead about ethical
implications scoping your stakeholders
this way is is just not reasonable right
you should also consider all of the
stakeholders who are affected or could
be affected by your software
as a concrete example perhaps we could
think about a company like uber or lyft
so under the software definition of
stakeholders you probably think about
like drivers and customers right like
those are the only two stakeholders who
really matter
but under the ethics protocol definition
of stakeholders you should think about
others too so the very obvious example
here is traditional taxi drivers who are
being undercut by these apps
you know it's impossible for you to
think of like every possible stakeholder
and every
potential effect that your software
could have it's just not tenable right
and so
there are things that will be out of
your control and you have to be okay
with that but nonetheless you should
still
try to anticipate as much as possible to
avoid those unintended consequences
downstream
i was curious what this all looks like
in the classroom
when students begin to put the ethics
protocol into practice
our course consists of essentially two
parts in the first part of the term
they're learning the basic design ideas
and the basic technologies and putting
them together and applying them on small
well-contained problems and then in the
second half of the term
they join together in teams and they
take on a larger project of their own
invention and they build that project
from concept you know to implementation
and deployment and everything we
introduce these social and ethical
concerns incrementally we start with the
individual assignments by asking them to
reflect on the ethical and social
ramifications
of the assignment they're doing and the
implications of that assignment and we
we slowly ramp up the intensity and the
sophistication
of the analysis that we ask from them
and then as we move towards the the
final project we ask them to begin to
take those decisions into account in
their own design work and then in the
final project we encouraged them to
develop their ideas
using these lenses that serena described
and in the context of this this kind of
analysis
and it was part of their deliverable
which i think is really important so it
wasn't just them talking about it it was
part of their grade and it felt very
real and important and i think we saw
the students like really participate and
start to you know integrate this into
their thinking partially as a
consequence of that integration
it was actually a surprise even to me
despite my enthusiasm for this material
that we found that there were
so many social and ethical concerns even
in the relatively narrow context of the
rather technical assignments at the
beginning
so i'll just give you one example you
know we we have them build
what we call fritta
you know fritter is essentially a
twitter clone but just questions
regarding for example what kinds of
posts are shown what the criteria are
for displaying posts uh tweets or freits
as we call them what order they appear
in and so on can have social
ramifications
at this point in the conversation i
started wondering what it was like to
teach ethics in the context of cancel
culture
but as daniel and serena explained
students aren't being taught what to
think
they aren't being asked to espouse
particular ideologies in the classroom
instead they're learning how to ask
better questions
we try not to be prescriptive sometimes
that can be quite hard because we all
have quite a strong sense of right and
wrong but instead what we're trying to
do mostly is to get the students to
question the decisions that they're
making and to try to
refine and iterate on their own moral
and ethical compasses and so we want
them to develop that understanding for
themselves through their own lens and
leave mit with that knowledge
just because something is subjective
just because we might not all agree
on our valuation of particular ethical
consequences
doesn't mean that we can't
attain some kind of objective
understanding of what it means to have a
competent ethical analysis
that is appropriately far-reaching
balanced and deep in in different
respects you know one of the things that
we're trying to teach the students is
that this isn't about any particular
ideology or dogma as serena explained
what we do is we we really give them
tools
and we provide them with these lenses
and we never suggest that any one
ethical evaluation is correct and
another one is incorrect you know we
don't say that uber should make his
decisions according to the impact on the
livelihood of existing taxi drivers nor
do we say that the shareholders of uber
are the most important stakeholders nor
do we say that the drivers or the or the
passengers are important the point is
that any design decision must be made
with a full awareness of which
stakeholders you're actually taking into
account and then how you actually do
that yourself well that's of course
tremendously important we're not for a
minute i'm suggesting to the students
that there's any kind of predefined
ethical judgments that we expect them to
make and on the contrary i think we'd
actually like to complicate their
understanding
you know my goal is always to persuade
the students and myself the
preconceptions that we come in with
are too simple-minded
and that there's a lot of work to be
done to understand things more deeply
as they develop these deeper
understandings students in daniel and
serena's software studio course are also
challenging stereotypes about the kind
of work engineering students can be
passionate about
our students it turns out you know are
absolutely passionate about making their
mark in the world and about being part
of a larger community i think it's just
a question of giving them the
opportunity to do this you know i
suspect if you asked them you know would
you like to take a course on social and
ethical ramifications of computing they
might not list it it's actually very
much parallels the experience of the
humanities at mit where students
generally don't
rush towards the humanities classes
they're required to take some as part of
their general institute requirements but
when they take those classes typically
they love them
and they love them not only because
they're a break from the much more
sometimes concrete and narrow thinking
that they do in their technical classes
but i think because it allows them to
bring their whole selves to their work
and it makes them feel that they have
agency and that they are actually
contributing in a in a broader and
deeper way
it isn't just the students who are being
prompted to think more deeply and
creatively about engineering coursework
so i think one of the challenges in
embedding cirque materials
is that the university experience is
like very much a bubble normally you're
working on kind of like toy problems
you're not shipping software right your
decisions kind of don't have social and
ethical implications because probably
your software isn't going to leave your
hands really like your ta will see it
your professor will see it but it's
still very closely held
so something that i struggle with is
trying to bridge this gap to having the
decisions that you make uh have like
real world consequences
and so in this class the way we tried to
approach it was by making it realistic
but it's still to some extent like
building in a sandbox and so i'm curious
about what other educators do to try to
make this like extremely real to your
students right how can we make the
social and ethical responsibilities
questions tangible
the other thing i would say that for me
is a very big challenge is that we're
constantly feeling overwhelmed by the
amount of technical material that we
need to teach
and we're finding ways to to reduce that
by preparing the students better in
earlier courses by flipping the
classroom more but i would welcome any
ideas that people have on how to switch
students out of this mindset that you
know just learning the details of the
programming language or the web platform
that they're using or whatever is is all
that matters and to get them to see
beyond that
if you have insights to share about
teaching social and ethical
responsibilities of computing please get
in touch with me through the link in our
show notes i'll pass your ideas along to
daniel serena and other listeners
if you're interested in learning more
about ethics and software design or
remixing daniel and serena's open
educational resources in your own
teaching head on over to our mit open
courseware website you'll find all the
materials there
thank you so much for listening until
next time signing off from cambridge
massachusetts and about to go google
pterodactyl i'm your host sarah hansen
from mit open courseware
chalk radio's producers include myself
fred poche and dave lashansky
scriptwriting assistance from aubrey
callaway
show notes for this episode were written
by peter chipman
and the circ resource site on ocw was
built by kathleen nalazetti
we're funded by mit open learning and
supporters like you